top fed officials signals interest rates
to stay on hold at September meeting
this is a financial time story uh Vinnie
I'm going to come to you on this
one finally just sitting here waiting
these numberss Christopher Waller a
Federal Reserve official suggested that
the central bank is likely to keep its
Benchmark interest rate unchanged at the
upcoming September meeting citing recent
economic data as not warranting imminent
monetary tightening Waller emphasize
there's nothing that is saying we need
to do anything in anytime soon wallers
remarks Echo Federal Reserve chair J pow
stands at Jackson Hall Wyoming Symposium
emphasizing a data- driven approach
recent labor market reports indicated a
slow slowing demand for workers in the
US prompting the FED to close the amount
of inflation indicators despite
improvements in inflation data Waller
remained cautious emphasizing the
importance of sustained Trends rather
than isolated reports Tom yeah so the
fed's going to get together September
19th and 20th but um J pal will not be
going upstairs to pound the cheerleader
she's going to get a break they not
going to raise rates Jesus it's um not
going to happen however on
Halloween Jerome Pal's going to dress as
somebody and they're going upstairs and
unless some of these soft economic
things that we're seeing we're probably
going to get a quartero increase on
October 31st and there's a lot of people
including me analysts that believe that
will be our last increase and then we're
got to get through the winter see how uh
Black Friday and fourth quarter goes and
everything like that but um hoping I'm
hoping there's none on October 31st but
it looks like with the softness we'll
probably get a quarter point but um
nothing in the next two weeks which is a
good thing when will be the first
decrease I think the first decrease I'm
I'm with the consensus on this February
the bigger Banks is um probably April
right at the beginning of second quarter
is you get a quarter point back but
here's what it here's what needs and
it's kind of bad what it need needs is
softer consumer spending so it doesn't
drive inflation prices and it needs a
little bit of softness in the labor
market so some uh layoffs and we're
seeing some of those we need a little
bit more softness in labor market to
keep wages down how much how much of
what Amazon does on Black Friday and
holiday season is going to kind of tell
us where consumer spending is and what
what how it's going to dictate interest
rates well I I happen to be very
interested in how the hell the US
consumer is going to make Black Friday
crazy when they've now drove their
consumer credit cards up to $1 trillion
how do they go nuts on Black Friday this
year if if if 30 days ago consumer
credit hit the largest total credit
balance of all time yeah I was just
going to go there if you follow the math
um so let's just follow some of the
numbers here for a second so the FED
funds rate right is what five and a
quarter 5 a half% right so that's the um
rate at which the Fed
lends money to or gives money to the
banks and then the prime rate which is
the the the number that banks will use
to basically disperse money to regular
people is usually around 3% higher than
the Fred funds rate so basically you're
talking fed fund rate five five and a
quarter five and a half to the prime
rate which would which you would receive
or or businesses would receive at about
eight and a half there's your mortgages
okay there are your mortgages exactly
but you brought up the best point the
average person out there you talked
about that credit card debt just passed
the trillion dollars student debts
already done it auto loans are already
there U mortgages are already 10
trillion whatever the number is over
there but speaking of credit card debt
you know the speaking prime rate being 8
and a half% do you know the average
credit card rate in America today the
average take a guess 24 19 and a half
19.9%
20% highest of all time um was 177% last
year so they're break breaking records
these not type of records that you want
to be breaking if you're an average
consumer so it's very important just pay
attention to the interest rates there it
is right there 20.9 21% if you just want
to round up okay listen if you're if
you're trying to make money investing a
good decent rate of return would be what
10% n 10% that's what the stock market
pays over time you're losing money going
the opposite way when you're trying to
go this way it it's disast and it's
killing your wealth guys listen cuz I
don't want to show off Pat and get into
all the finance stuff but everything
that you and Tom said I concur so
that's AG my constituents are 100 I
talked I just appreciate that do you
know the cap on credit card debt with
like the highest they can charge you do
you know what it is no clue 30% wow
that's like that's all that you're
they're allowed to so right now to be
HED let's start a credit card company
well that's a big business to get into
but what they're starting to do is the
the the the level of regulation and
scrutiny right now with Visa Mastercard
the the world they're dealing with it's
not what it used to be because a lot of
guys see these numbers and they're like
let's go into the credit card business
it's not what you think it is there used
to be a lot of money in it years ago
they they've kind of regulations hurt
them a little bit uh still profitable
but it takes a lot more to get into it
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here